i call this gentleman with respect
attending from hell
hey what's up guys welcome back to my
channel and in this video i'm going to
be interviewing a property millionaire
who has over a dozen properties he's
built up over the last many years
actually he's been in business since
1984 when he started a nursing home he
is now on the property investors academy
his rent roll is 6 000 pounds a month
and he's absolutely killing it in
property but in this video he's going to
be sharing what he what his successes
have been but also where he's made
mistakes what he wished he knew then
which he now knows now his goals for the
future but more importantly the mindset
of somebody who can get through a
recession who can become a property
millionaire so i think you're going to
really enjoy this one why don't you
subscribe hit the like button and doug
welcome to my house thank you so you've
been in property for many years you've
also been in business since before i was
even born so why don't you start by just
sharing you know what is it that made
you want to get into business want to
get into property where did that desire
to become an investor come from thank
you
yeah initially i came from zimbabwe many
years ago into uk
because there were no opportunities
actually in that particular country and
as a fact we're at war when i go to this
country i found most people just go to a
job and make a living nothing wrong with
that that's fine
then i realized the more i become an
employee for somebody else all i had was
a paycheck
sadly i found
paycheck i couldn't even last a month in
other words there was more money left at
the end of every
paycheck for me
that's when i really started to go into
business
and my first business basically was in
building a nursing home that's when i
became in love with this industry of
property and was that in the uk or in
zimbabwe iranian the united kingdom oh
that was here in the uk so you came from
zimbabwe yes and you started your first
business in the uk in 1994 that was
before i was even born um and and did
that go well
well it went very well because i bought
a property literally
which was a disused property no roof no
walls nothing and everybody laughed at
me they absolutely laughed at me
and then i realized no i listened to a
gentleman called walt disney he said to
himself
he had seven friends
if he introduced any good idea to seven
people and they
even one of them said it was a bad idea
or a good idea you wouldn't do it
if all said no he would go and do it
because he realized majority of the
population are going the wrong way
so when my friend said no to me this
this building anyway i found an
opportunity in other words i found a
derelict and a building to over a
million pounds worth of property that's
how i'm finished with it
wow and that was just the first one
you've gone on now you've bought over a
dozen properties you've shown me the
list and all the addresses and they you
know it's great i mean you're property
millionaire you're financially free but
for you you're just getting started i
mean you tell me when you when you came
onto the train and you were like
like pinching yourself saying i wish i'd
known this earlier
what what what what is it that you know
now
that you wish you knew
all those years ago okay
yeah i appreciate you calling me
probably melania which i am but i
realize again talking to my mentor john
c maxwell he said
if you make become a millionaire on your
own it's a shame because that is really
peaceful when you become a
multi-millionaire with it in other words
with a team you can actually achieve
lots lots more
so that's the reason why i feel i could
have done more
with what i had but it doesn't matter
yeah
yeah
you say it doesn't matter but you
constantly tell me i wish i'd known that
i wish i'd known that you know yeah um
you're quite um you know you're quite
well established in property why would
someone as established as you that's
making good money that's financially
free still be continually coming down to
these courses reading books getting
mentors
why do you do that still
right as i said i came from a country or
way back in africa which is very poor
i've never forgotten my roots
the people where i come from are really
very poor economically and everything
else and i realized i'm one of those
people we should go back not physically
but go back and help my people i'll give
an example
people are drinking dirty water which
means it's killing a lot of people
through bilateral other diseases anyway
and again there's no electricity which
means there's no functionality in terms
of people being creative there's nothing
like that so i think i owe it to my
family back home to do what i could here
then go back home and help my people
and i think it's probably that
motivation that why power that kind of
keeps you so hungry because you know you
could be i can be in a room with 100
people
and
most of the guys in the room
have got no properties they're not
making any money from property maybe
it's a free seminar you're there on the
front row you're more motivated than
nearly everybody else but you've already
got a million pound property in fact
much more than that
but but but you you're still hungry and
i think that's probably because you've
got a strong why how important do you
think having a reason is in this
business
yeah to me it's everything
it really is everything why do i say
that the energy i get today is more than
i've ever had before especially now that
i found an opportunity with the summer
leads organization
i can see the opportunity i can see
whether people have produced i can see
what i could do with more to help other
people
my life is okay now
but to help those people which i would
really strong passion for
uh nothing is too you know too much
energy for me to go and do that
and
why do you think property because i know
you've got you've had several businesses
and you've recently kind of came to the
conclusion that property is the most
lucrative right you've got you've got a
network marketing business which is
going really well um you've had several
businesses you've had your nursing home
but you kind of you recently said to me
if i put all my attention on property
because that's what's bringing in the
most money anyway if you put more
attention into that
then you think that that's probably the
smartest way forward what is it about
property that you think is so lucrative
and you enjoy so much
well there are about three things really
with properties number one is this
passion to see how much i can excel
because
right now i feel i have nowhere near to
my
potential nowhere near
number two
getting to see what's available right
now it means
by me succeeding
i'm going to touch a lot of other people
to succeed i really believe in win-win
situation
and number three it just really means
really at the moment i'm not using all
the energy whether mentally or
physically that i what it's given me
anyway to achieve
so it's my ambition really that i'm just
at the beginning so you think property
there's scope to scale it and grow it
big
a hundred percent yeah i think i'd agree
with that and there's you know there's
some businesses that have almost got a a
capacity
whereas property if you look on the
sunday times rich list that's what
everyone's doing you know that's that's
where they're putting their money in i
mean i know a lot of people that have
got a business the business is
successful and then they start investing
into property and then the property
business massively overtakes the
business that happens all the time
in business another interesting thing is
how did we connect because i know you
saw evan's video talk to me a little bit
about that
right
for me really my condition was an
accident i don't know what i was just
watching on youtube and i saw this
gentleman is evans somebody i've had you
know some dealings with before
and i thought
what's this guy doing
in actual fact in my last network
marketing he was like somebody i was
teaching whatever we were doing now i
see this guy here is a property almost
immediately and i'm thinking
what am i doing that i should be doing
so he was the one person who really
inspired me and when i heard what you
told him whatever you're talking about
and i'm thinking
ah now i know it's not just heavens
is what truth is you using who is the
teacher who is guiding him that really
inspired me to come and find you yeah
nice because you've known evans for many
years millions and um you know he came
down and he
he saw what you were doing in network
marketing yeah attending some of the
classes looked up to you saw you as a
mentor and as a role model and then you
then saw him and were like man what is
going on um and the video's blown up
it's had like almost quarter of a
million views now and um you know it's
fabulous so in your years of property
investing then what would you say have
been some of your biggest mistakes
yeah
mistake number one is not having enough
knowledge that to me really is the
biggest mistake i ever made number two
uh i really didn't have the focus that
the
the business you know entirely i'd had
my eyes on other things that i was doing
because i love you know personal
development so i was focusing more on
that developing other people and not
realizing i could be developing that as
well as proper time as well okay
and also you've got a lot of tenants
so you know with the amount of
properties that you've got and the
amount of tenants that you've got um you
know is that is it has it been smooth
sailing have you had a lot of
nightmare tenants have you had some
disasters or has have you been pretty
fortunate
now one thing i really did right in the
first place was to find really the
managing team
i've always relied on you know letting
agencies to do the work for me because
that is an area i didn't have the time
to do it or they know how to do it so
i've been almost lucky in terms that
over all these years only one tenant has
given me any challenges
yeah unfortunately that tenant gave me
challenges every time that i met you so
it's been plain selling i hope it wasn't
to do with me that that tenant
[Laughter]
what is it what happened with the tenant
you know when they say look when
when the
student is ready the teacher will appear
this tenant really was just somebody
challenging individual you know he
didn't want to pay the rent he didn't
want to accept you know workman go into
this place and then he complains it was
a vicious cycle just
what about somebody you know i call this
gentleman with respect attending from
hell okay but anyway uh that's the only
time i ever had any chance of attendance
otherwise mostly i relied on alleging
agencies to do the work what happened
with this ten what did you do
well this particular talent anyway is
one thing led to another the first thing
is he was made redundant and then he
couldn't pay the rent and then he was
being given money by the council anyway
but he was just difficult somebody
really rude crude somebody how did you
get rid of him well i would read them
literally through having to go through
the lawyers well i had to employ a
lawyer to actually begin to send letters
and fortunately just before he was
pushed he jumped he moved out
and sometimes you know when you've got a
lot of tenants
you've been in property for many years
it is gonna happen that sometimes you
have this type of problem
how important is mental toughness and
having the right mindset in this
business
well mental toughness i think it's
everything because if you really haven't
got this longevity long-term
basis anyways we can look at just now uh
even these challenges for me that is a
part of success
i welcome them
because i normally find people that know
more than i do and bring in that
knowledge anyway which i haven't got i'm
quite humble to do that i've never been
you know i've got to know everything
so bringing in the experts has always
been my channel of success that's really
really interesting that you say that so
it's so it's important to
have a good team around you
i guess with property you need a good
management company
which you've had and also solicitors
accountants um what would you say if you
were advising yourself from say 20 years
ago
you know your your younger self that was
just starting to want to get into
property and starting to get fair first
tenants what advice would you give your
younger self
i think number one really is to have a
plan that's really would be the number
one
i think somebody somebody said you know
you're going to plan your battles and
battle your bone plants
or you can either plan to fail fail to
plan that sort of thing anyway so having
a plan of exactly where you're going
would be the first thing i didn't have
any right because the reason why i was
buying these properties i was buying
them for my staff because i owned a
nursing home people came from overseas
they have nowhere to live i'll buy a
property okay you can go and rent there
you can go and run there it was not
structured it was almost an accidental
activity so my younger server device
look
focus
having a plan of action where are you
going in that particular area and follow
that plan
interesting and what now
in 2022 do you think is the best way to
invest in property
right
for now really is number one you need to
have a mentor to me that is central
behind the mentor i need to have the
ability to want to learn
which i think is so important number
three i don't look back anymore but
looking back is not where i want to be
i've got to really be futuristic where
am i going okay find a way to get there
and more importantly having a team
around me um
why do you think it's so important to
have a mentor okay
yeah see like i said to you before i
became a millionaire property
millionaire on on my own
until i read this wonderful book by john
c maxwell he says it's a shame if you
become successful on your own whereas if
you can have a team around you i
remember someone said you can go fast if
you go run on your own but you can go
further with the team yeah so i've
always really encompassed who can i work
with who can i find you know align with
i think in this industry called joint
ventures i didn't know that terminology
but i just knew the way team
t-e-a-m together everyone achieved small
yeah yeah brilliant and when did you get
your first mentor when did you start
when did you start active when did you
have this switch that was i've bought
all these houses but i've just done it
on my own without a strategy without a
plan i've left money on the table i
haven't got the returns that i would
have got i thought i've been more
if i'd have been more strategic when did
you come to the conclusion that i need
to start instead of paying for my
mistakes and leaving money on the table
i should put a little bit of money into
my education when when did that happen
yeah i think the realization came way
back one of my first properties 2007
i actually bought a off plan
and this particular group of people
actually sent me to do the the what i
can go the online education we went for
training this cost me six thousand
pounds
i was disgruntled by the what i got for
my six thousand pounds therefore i gave
up all that learning until like i said
i came to the realization that i've got
all these properties here
and what can i do with them there's a
lot i want to do but there's no another
way i can do other leverage but in the
property where that's the time that i
was very fortunate to really meet up
with your organization so do you think
that that bad experience of the training
program which you felt under delivered
do you think that kind of put you off
doing any property education
putting more writing is an
understatement
because i've spent so much time because
to me it's not about the amount i spend
is the value i get on my investment yeah
nothing's for free i didn't mind paying
6000 pounds anyway then but what i got
for six thousand pounds was no support
there was no nothing
you know it was just like falling off a
cliff
and that really put me off that's why i
value when i met up with you with
everything that you do for us i think i
said myself is this for real
is something just being pretentious now
i know it's for real that's why i'm here
in the organization when i first when
you first came to an event and i sold
the academy and i said you get unlimited
mentoring you get all the did you think
really
no offense
it was just too good to be true yeah
from my previous experiences
and then as i begin to stay on the
training and i begin to see success upon
success upon success i'm thinking
those people don't look anything
different from me i'm not better than
anybody else but nobody's better than me
there must be something on this channel
where are they learning from that's the
reason why i begin to nudge into and
find out a bit more information so you
when did you join the academy about two
three months ago about four weeks ago
actually in general wow so not long just
been a month and you've obviously met a
lot of other people
how's your first month been
the first month has been absolutely
discovered learning because or they have
come to other trainings like the um
crash courses anyway
now i'm just beginning to put everything
in
my ducks in a row to understand really
each strategy has got a place to play
because i was so confused until you said
to us we can reach out to other people i
remember talking to tony mr tony crook
he really was guy with
he helped me a lot
that you're looking at too many things
okay he told me about an example but a
lion if you ever got a lion you know
with a learner get a chair a lion will
be looking at those four
legs anyway it won't know what you want
to attack
so that's what i was doing here all
these strategies were just too many for
me and tony said find one and focus on
that yeah yeah that's great focus is
really important and also as you've said
the thing you've kept saying over and
over is have a plan have a plan have a
plan and courses are great property
training courses but i think it's also
really important as you say to have a
mentor to have somebody that can guide
you and walk you through where you are
where you want to go and every strategy
is just a tool really isn't it to unlock
your next step in your journey so so
what's next then so after all your
experience in business and property now
being part of the academy and i know you
only joined the academy a month ago but
you've been coming to the courses for
the last few months you've been in the
community for a lot longer than a month
so what's next then what's the plan for
you this year yeah the plan this year
really is to really again sit down the
mementos to have a look at what i've got
way forward so that we can begin to
restructure what i have is
not where i want to be there's a lot of
potential with the type of properties
i've got but i'm put the wrong
strategy into these properties in other
words it's only singulate
okay which is okay but that's not where
i want to be yeah so i want to
re-strategize all my systems anyway
what's one of the biggest things that
you've learned over the last month
where do i start from anyway i'll go
ahead
number one i've said i i learned that
the mentorship is for real
however to have a tool and not use it
you'll be done before
so it's important i utilize the access
have the access of the tools that you
have given us we've got all the online
you know we've got all the literally the
books we've also got the actual
live you know shows as well i want to
make sure i can really utilize every
single one of those things but more
importantly learn with a mentor guiding
me and i remember when i said from stage
one of the training programs you should
be making a minimum of 500 pounds per
property
and you were like oh because your
properties don't make 500 pounds a month
profit and that's profit so you're
making you're financially free your rent
roll is about six just over six grand
profits about half that right which is
good and you're financially free and
that's more than an average job will
give you and um you're financially free
but of course you want to do
much more than that so you know what
what was the big lesson there for you
this lesson there really is like i said
to you once you have got is someone
guiding you and being able to listen and
more importantly get into action it's
okay to have the knowledge but if you
start you know
all the time it's not going to happen
you've got to get into action
and but follow the guidelines yeah we
should plan of it anywhere else i really
believe is that who you're who you're
around is who you become i think it's
important to have a good environment and
you know i don't know what what advice
would you give to someone that's just
starting out or wants to get started in
property but all their friends are maybe
a little bit negative skeptical
their family
saying be careful be careful
because that's that can be really
challenging when you're starting out i
know i've experienced that i've had a
lot of my friends when i started out
that were sort of holding me back um
what advice would you give to someone
that's in the wrong environment that's
wanting to become successful in property
yeah i think this is saying really we
become who we associate with i remember
gentleman said in five years one was
going to be exactly the same person
except for two things the people he
mixed with the books you read
so if you look around we all have to
look around and say i said who are the
five people i associate with i know
sometimes it's family and people very
close to you people with some selling
they miss you or people share the bed
with and whatever it is anyway but one
is going to make a mental note and said
okay
these people here don't pay my bills
if i listen to what they've got to say
i'm buying their lifestyle is that where
i want to be
yeah
now is it easy to placate yourself from
these people
what you've got to make a determination
but at the end of the day if someone is
jumping you in the back anyway are you
going to stay oh by the way your own
family keep on doing that
so i find really you have got to find
the people that are going to take you
from people like stairways they either
take you up will take you down you know
what people always undermining your
efforts already undermining everything
else why would you stay with that person
so my advice to anybody is
you need to know which side your bread
is battered yeah where can you get the
values that you are looking for in life
rather than just a morning grown in that
environment you gave us the example for
the dog in you know in the in the in the
chair whatever it is anyway yeah if that
dog was you know always howling it's
sitting on that nail
well maybe it's not hating enough
but when you know it's hurting you
and the future is not where you want to
be
you've got to take action
and what's the best advice you could
give
for finding new friends and get building
up a power team
how how how would one go about that from
scratch right number one really you can
build a power team inside your house
everything we need is outside our house
yeah step outside
yeah find you know for example clubs
social clubs or find uh some interest
for yourself whether it's stop
collecting or you know knitting or
building or whatever it is anyway
find people that share the same values
and interests like you don't be
pretentious because you pretend that you
like you know that particular
association it's going to show that your
heart is not in it yeah find something
that you like and in there you're going
to find people that will inspire you
really to the next step in your own life
how important you mention about the
people you hang around with in the books
you read how important has reading been
as part of your success
right
this to me really i mean i'm almost
obsessed about reading why is that
well i'm a christian it's always i'm not
trying to share them with the bible but
in there it says really
read and whatever you read can be
laughing for other people behind you to
look at because when you read books
the people that are writing this book
the professionals by the way they're
spending years researching that book
how much does it cost you pennies
yes
it's
like no life's worth all you need to do
is read it
look no one is asking usually saying to
you you've got to do everything else in
that book no find the things that are
going to help you
and to me that's one of the most
important thing to read
i guess yeah when someone pulls their
whole life experiences into a book
to not read that would be would be crazy
really so you've read a lot of books
what are some of the best books that
you've read over the years
some of them was already believed people
like robert kiyosaki i think most of us
were raised that reached that point yeah
i wrote another book in the cash flow
quadrant which is good
and then on the other side video go
people like napoleon hill king and grow
rich yeah there's a book again 17
principles in there and each principle
is helping you even how we associate
with people or how to think i'll take
initiative he's teaching all that and
another book i love really is by john c
maxo he is a leadership guru why is that
important because some of us really we
have almost reached a ceiling in what we
think we can do
but as long as we reach that ceiling we
give up on that only to realize he said
no don't do that the law of the lead is
saying
you you have not maximized exactly what
you need to learn find someone who knows
more than you do they lift you up yeah
and then the book again which is read by
dale carnegie how to win friends and
influence people which again you've
recommended to me to me really it's
so important to go out there and mix
with other human beings
but more importantly today i'm not just
saying this because i'm here
and please check it as a compliment
i've never met anybody in my life of
reading i've been reading i've been a
teacher for many years
somebody who
lives the books like you do every
whenever you're talking i can almost see
the book that you're talking about
you are somebody i really really from
the bottom of my heart admire you you
are very well read person okay and it
comes out almost in every lecture i can
see the book that you're talking about
not by name
but just bring out the quotations or
bring out the information so reading to
me is everything well we know leaders
are readers right and the readers are
leaders yeah without that for me i think
i wouldn't be where i am today damn doug
you've made me want to just stop and go
read a book right now you know
but it's so true it's so and some of the
books you you you name it absolute
classics how to win friends and
influence people by dow carnegie um the
the the um
another one is the seven habits of
highly effective people i know you've
read it and that's the thing it's it's
if you're in a room with people that are
self-made millionaires
guaranteed they've all read the same
books you know they've all read the same
books and they're also then they're in
they're in circles with other winners
because who you're around is ultimately
who you'll become so um okay so with
property specifically then
when you're buying a property how do you
know whether a deal is a good deal or
not and this is what i'm now learning
now
number one what is a good deal number
one first thing is really it's going to
be a win-win situation for me and the
person i'm buying from two it is going
to make sense
yeah is there what am i looking for i'm
looking for you know to create a value
what value can i do or get any from that
particular deal so it's a deal is many
facets it's a win-win situation is it
going to work for me uh am i going to
get the income that i'm looking at yeah
nice and i think that's so important
it's not about win-win because it's not
about trying to be cut throat and it's
about actually if someone's selling and
they want a quick sale they might be
happy to drop the price or it might be
that there's value to be added
it could turn into flats but the seller
doesn't have the time or the inclination
to do that so you're buying it you're
adding value and you're getting paid
handsomely as um as you know as a result
so um what's your strongest reason you
mentioned about your um your payment
your passion to go back home and to give
back and to help people that are um less
fortunate than many of us in
in the uk are with hospitals and
drinking water which is really admirable
um what what are the other reasons
what's your the reason that gives you
such a fire to want to succeed in
winning business
i think one thing i'm looking for is
being a
be a person of meaning
or significance in life
yes not just me me me i've got a car
whether house i can go on holiday to me
that's not what it's all about
why
my mission is can i make this world a
better place in a small measure
than the world i found it
and to me really that's everything i
remember very clearly someone said
really look it's like chinese foreign
when a tiger dies it leaves these
stripes when a man or woman dies they
leave their name
what name are people going to be talking
about that judo not as an egotistic
journey no what have i done to
contribute to the betterment of other
human beings yeah powerful and i think
as well sometimes people say to me um
they say samuel when will enough be
enough
and the answer is well
never because i'm never going to get to
a point where i say i've achieved enough
now i've got enough houses i've made
enough money because it's not about the
money or about how many houses it's
about the significance about being the
best version of myself and about leaving
something so you know i think the moment
that you say i can retire now i know
you'll never retire you're never going
to get to a point where you just switch
off and stay at home and watch the news
and your slippers you're always going to
have that fire and um you know it's
interesting because i think people think
that when they make three thousand four
thousand pounds a month passive income
like what you're doing they'll retire
but actually
the human beings are meant to be
continually progressing and growing and
if you're not growing you're dying so
it's great to see that following you as
someone that's been in property for
longer than i've been even even in this
world but still to this day got that
fire in your belly and and learning and
growing it's really inspiring so what
would be your final words of wisdom or
advice to someone watching this
interview wanting to get started in
property from the beginning what would
you say their first step should be
i think the first thing like i said to
begin easy you have whatever your
will the reason why you want to do this
that's really important because we all
have what they can call fads i want to
do is i want to do that and it doesn't
last two minutes number one number two
find somebody who can actually guide you
on this journey because fumbling through
anything that you want to do you're
going to get tired you're going to
really
bump into obstacles yeah okay there's
always somebody that answers somewhere
else do that
so you need to mention anyway and then
finally stay the course
whatever advice it's really is almost
rude when people give you advice and you
don't take it you might as well not ask
for it yeah
so uh once again
there's a lot of help around ask
somebody it's not about being humble no
it's about really finding information
once you can do that the road ahead is
so plentiful and more importantly i
always say to myself
i'm going to be living a life of
abundance yes that's really the key for
all of us there's plenty in the world
you can say well because someone's a
millionaire they've taken my my sled of
the cake no we always make money all the
time when there's not enough of us
making this money okay it's an
ever-ending story so i think the
abundance for me is very important
that's great and also you've spoken a
lot about finding a mentor and of course
you know depending on what you're
wanting to learn some people might want
it to be i always say to people if you
want to if you want a mentor that's
going to help you get a six-pack
i'm not your guy you know you want to
find someone that's actually achieved
what you want to achieve
you might be looking for a mentor even
in in how to become an actor or how to
learn a musical instrument so um but i
guess the question is and this isn't
just in property but just in general
what what things would you say because
there's good mentors there's bad mentors
there's good training courses there's
bad you've experienced some training
courses that were so bad that they put
you off for what almost almost 15 years
you know i know you know before before
you finally got recovered and said right
i'm gonna give it another go but what
would you say
advice would you say how do you find a
good mentor what things should you be
looking for because there's a lot of
people out there that aren't good
there's a lot of fakes out there um
what would you say you should be looking
for to be able to tell whether someone
is actually a good mentor or not
thank you again for that question i
think here's the deal we can either
lower the bar okay and lose all the big
people in your own life or you can raise
the bar of your own life and win all the
winners so here it is when i found you
and please i take this as a compliment i
just didn't find somebody as a mentor i
find somebody who walks his walk that's
very important the people they talk to
talk they do nothing and number two
i just love the energy honestly there's
something you have
if even on a picture your picture is
always you know man in action and i love
that you wherever you are you are the
person who lights up the room as soon as
you walk in that room because of your
energy so to have a mentor in you
to me
i can never have enough of you if you
see my point yeah no i appreciate that i
appreciate it i mean that was put on my
hat no thank you and i think as well one
of the interesting things you said
earlier was and i know one of the
reasons that you chose to join the
property investors academy was you were
seeing all these successful people and
it all pointed back to the source of and
i think for me if i'm looking at if i
because i get a lot of mentors myself
you know i pay you know i invest in my
education one of the things i look for
in a mentor is who have they mentored
before and what
what has the fruit been you know you can
you can tell somebody according to their
fruits
right so if if someone's saying oh i'm a
mentor and i teach people but they
haven't actually really got many
students
and it's like well where's the fruit of
what am i gonna whereas if someone's got
loads of mentors like grant cardone for
instance grant cardone loads of people
have been
impacted have been touched have been
through his training and as a result
there's fruit um and i think the same
with robert kiyosaki you know how many
people have read rich dad poor dad and
have and have credited that book even
myself have said it was it was rich dad
poor dad so to say oh richard poor
that's a terrible book it's like well no
because there's there's fruit from the
book there's
millions of people across the world that
have
become financially independent and have
credited that book as the beginning of
the journey so there's fruit from the
book so i think you know if someone's
saying they're a mentor they've got a
course i would be saying where is the
fruit where are the students that have
succeeded as a result of that course or
that book or that seminar or that
teacher i think that's one of the best
ways um to tell and of course are they
walking the walk themselves how long
have they been in the industry have they
got proof of that
and then as you said the energy
sometimes you have to go on your gut
feeling as well a little bit your
intuition
but that's amazing well i really
appreciate you coming down and it's been
such a pleasure working with you for the
last um for the last few months thank
you ladies and gentlemen i hope you
enjoyed that interview filled with
wisdom from doug who is a true gentleman
he's not only a property millionaire
and financially free but he's also got a
really good heart and a heart to help
others and see other people win so if
you enjoyed the video then why don't you
go ahead and smash the like button if
you want to come down to the property
investors crash course and you want to
meet me in person and meet other people
then why don't you um join the property
investors crash course i'm gonna leave a
link in the description there are free
tickets available but they are very
limited so get yourself booked right now
subscribe enjoy the whole playlist with
hundreds of people that have been
through my training that are financially
free over here and i'll see you next
time
[Music]